she would turn my blue jacket yes and
after a very intense conversation with
their sales woman that ended with both
of us in tears I got you a full refund a
while back
absolutely this computer isn't taking
the pass it's my laptop it'll bring me
my laptop
wake me up at midnight but don't start
early play a lullaby or something that
just slowly increased the volume what
are you still doing here I'm always the
last one here I'm always the last one
here the two of them are always in this
office let's just lock him in a room
together sneaking up sex with each other
when they're boning we're free we wanted
to shut down the elevator for a few
minutes there two people could fall in
love well who's this guy you need to go
sir it's go time
oh my god this is how it always starts
in my nightmare what are you doing what
is he doing stop doing that please stop
that right I need to them free of this
we know everything about them but they
like what they don't like we're the men
behind the curtain does Rick have a good
game Keys tickets no he watches from the
bleachers like a common peasant yeah of
course he does we need two people these
two seats to make out
take you the rest of the day I'm a being
late tomorrow forget it we meet two
miserable people happy I'm proud of us
you guys know each other we're friends
that's nice why'd you say like that
how'd your voice
[Music]
I'll break up I'm not gonna pretend to
let him teach me about how the world
works
well one parent rapping no more not okay
I think I've seen the Lindsay Lohan
classic enough times to know that we're
full-on parents wrapping card all I care
about that I'm not still an assistant
one I'm 28 I'm 28 oh my god I'm so sorry
for you that's very sad for you
you
[Music]
you